pensemos un poco en las derivadas
parciales de campos vectoriales un campo
vectorial como ya vimos es una función
bueno en esta ocasión trabajaremos con
un ejemplo en dos dimensiones así que
pongamos algo que tiene dos dimensiones
como entrada y como salida vamos a
obtener el mismo número que el número de
entradas esto es importante y cada una
de estas componentes de salida va a
depender de las variables de entrada así
que por ejemplo en mi primera componente
se me ocurre poner a x x
en la segunda componente que cuadrada
menos equis cuadrada entonces puedes
calcular alguna derivada parcial de este
campo verdad bueno puedes tomarte no sé
la derivada de p con respecto a algunas
de las variables por ejemplo x la
derivada de b con respecto a x ok y se
calculamos esto bueno vamos a obtener
otra función de x de james y lo que
realmente estamos haciendo es tomarnos
las derivadas parciales de cada una de
las componentes así que en la primera
componente x se toma como una variable y
como una constante y por lo tanto me va
a quedar simplemente james la derivada
parcial de la segunda componente bueno
observa que ya se ve como una constante
por lo tanto esto no aparece y solamente
nos quedamos con la derivada de menos x
cuadrada con respecto a x que es menos
2x
así que de una forma analítica si sabes
cómo tomar la derivada parcial entonces
puedes tomar la derivada parcial de una
función vectorial y por lo tanto de un
campo vectorial ahora la parte divertida
e importante es cómo lo vamos a
interpretar bueno todo esto se puede
hacer en una manera visual así que vamos
a hacerlo bien la razón por la cual
llamamos a un campo vectorial de esta
manera es porque si tomamos todo el
plano x en cada uno de los puntos va a
representar un vector por ejemplo si
tomamos de entrada no se pensemos en un
punto en particular en el punto 12
entonces este punto donde x es igual a 1
y desigualdad 2 lo podemos asociar con
el vector salida que es bueno si lo
calculamos con x igual a 1 y 2 tengo 1
por 2 lo cual estos y después tengo 2 al
cuadrado menos 1 al cuadrado lo cual es
3 entonces tenemos el vector 23 asociado
con este punto de entrada y lo que
tenemos en un campo vectorial
tomamos un vector y lo pegamos a un
punto lo ancla a este punto en donde mi
componente x es de 2 en mi componente y
en este 3 así que pega este vector más o
menos así a este punto y bueno esto pasa
para todos los puntos del plano en
nuestro campo vectorial y si lo hacemos
al final terminaríamos con algo así
recuerda cuando calculas esto
especialmente en una computadora esto
tiende a mentirte un poco ya que en cada
punto tenés un vector pero este se vería
muy pero muy pequeño a comparación de lo
que realmente se presenta aquí pero
bueno en la realidad no podemos poner
todos los vectores en este plano sin que
se viera todo amontonado y bueno aquí
también quiero mencionar otra cosa el
color lo que nos da es un vago sentido
de longitud donde los azules representan
un vector mucho pero mucho más chico que
los de color amarillo así que esto nos
da una pequeña idea de qué tan largo es
un vector ahora bien las derivadas
parciales nos van a dar cosas más
específicas porque si piensas un poco
interpretamos una derivada parcial en
cualquier contexto te vas a dar cuenta
que en realidad lo pensamos como un
pequeño jalón en este caso en la
dirección x así que si ésta es nuestra
entrada original aquí tenemos un pequeño
jalón y el valor de este jalón es el
número que representa tu derivada
parcial en x así que la pregunta será
cuál es el cambio resultante para esta
salida y esto porque bueno la salida es
un vector y además también es el cambio
en la salida así que vamos a decir que
tenemos otro vector ligado a este mismo
punto cierto no sé tal vez sea algo así
puede ser algo similar o algo
ligeramente distinto y vamos a querer
tomar el cambio en este vector dividido
entre el cambio de este pequeño jalón
original a ver intentaré ser más
específico si estás comparando dos
vectores diferentes y se están
arraigados a dos puntos diferentes
entonces sería mucho más fácil si
movemos el espacio para anclar dos al
mismo punto al menos esto para empezar
así que vamos a dibujar otro espacio un
espacio distinto por aquí y piensa este
espacio original como el espacio en
donde viven estos vectores así que voy a
poner un nuevo espacio por ejemplo y si
hacemos eso entonces este primer vector
que tiene como componentes 2 3 no se
pongámosle un nombre le voy a poner el
nombre de b uno va a estar justo aquí y
por otro lado tenemos el jalón de salida
a este segundo vector le vamos a llamar
b 2 y voy a decir que también vive en
este espacio pero voy a exagerar
esta diferencia solo para que sea
visible así que digamos que es diferente
en cualquier forma pero ligeramente
diferente imagina que estos son dos
vectores y ahora la diferencia entre
estos dos vectores va a ser otro vector
que va a conectar a la cabeza de este
vector con la cabeza de este otro vector
ya este le voy a llamar a dv ahora la
forma en la que podemos pensar esto es
decir que si a b1 es decir al vector
original
vamos el vector debe es decir este
pequeño cambio que se observa es la
diferencia entre ambos esto me va a dar
b 2 es decir el cambio en la salida y es
que observa si lo pensamos en términos
de caracola lo puedes ver bastante fácil
el vector de verde más el vector de azul
nos da el vector de rosa que conecta me
observa la cola con la cabeza del
segundo bien ahora cuando estamos
hablando de derivadas parciales
básicamente lo que estamos diciendo es
gay
qué pasa si tomo el tamaño del jalón de
salida y lo divido por el salón de
entrada así que vamos a pensarlo en
términos de nuestro cambio original que
no sé supongamos que tiene un tamaño de
0.5 este es el cambio en la dirección en
x y entonces cuál es el cambio en ven en
el vector b con respecto al cambio en x
que básicamente seremos diciendo que
este vector hay que escalarlo por 2 es
decir este pequeño debe es la mitad de
tamaño que este otro vector el vector
que equivale a la derivada parcial
entonces este otro vector el vector de
azul el que tiene un tamaño muy grande
es la derivada de b con respecto a x en
su forma escalada y bueno esto tiene
sentido porque piensa la acción en un
principio está parcial x es muy pero muy
pero muy pequeña no sé supongamos que es
de 1 sobre 100 un centésimo ésta sería
de un centésimo o algo de ese orden y
entonces la derivada con respecto a x
sería un vector con un tamaño normal y
el punto al que señala nos indica la
dirección a la cual este vector de verde
cambiarían cuando se está moviendo bueno
para hacer más concretos que te parece
si calculamos este vector entonces vamos
a fijarnos en la derivada de b con
respecto a x en el punto 12 y bueno esto
también va a ser un vector va a ser el
vector donde lleva al de todos entonces
a que me queda 2 y sigue vale 12 x vale
1 aquí tengo menos 2 y bueno puedes ver
que aquí en definitiva mi dibujo está
mal porque ahora sabemos quién es el
vector de rosa
ahora tenemos un cambio de dos y menos
dos que se va a ver más o menos si
borramos la dirección incorrecta por
aquí todo esto y ponemos un cambio en la
dirección en x de 2 y en la componente
de menos 2 entonces el vector derivada
se va a ver algo como esto así que el
pequeño jalón en tve que buscábamos es
un vector que va en esta dirección algo
en esta dirección y esto significa que
el campo vectorial cuando te mueves y
cuando consideras que varios vectores se
anclan en cada uno de los puntos bueno
cuando pasas por el punto 12 la forma en
la que los vectores están cambiando es
una forma que va a hacer la derecha y
hacia abajo así que debemos y los
dibujamos y borramos esto que ya sabemos
que está mal va a ser un pequeño jalón
que bueno se va a ver algo así es más
pequeño en la dirección de james y más
grande en la dirección x porque está
cambiando conforme lo que nos dicta
héctor de azul y bueno en el siguiente
vídeo vamos a ver más ejemplos de todo
esto para que te quede mucho más claro
lo que esto significa y sobre todo lo
que significa en términos de cada
componente y bueno es que todo esto nos
va a servir para otros temas como la
divergencia y el rotacional así que nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo